hello everyone
good morning good evening good afternoon
from wherever you're watching this
year's sbi 2
2020 7th annual meeting uh we're very
grateful for you coming and spending
your time with us
i'm very honored to introduce our first
keynote speaker
lena nielsen is a vp of data science at
recursion
which is a biotech that is reimagining
drug discovery using machine learning
she was previously a ceo of analytic and
an innovation director at uc berkeley
her writings on open science social
impact technologies and gender and tech
have been published in the new york
times washington post in science
she has a phd in biomedical engineering
from eth zurich
and she's going to be talking to us
about some of the technologies that
recursion has been building
to help turn images into the answers to
questions and the cures for diseases
um with that we're all very excited to
watch luna's talk so take it away lena
hello everyone i'm excited to be here
virtually
to share a bit about recursion
pharmaceuticals and how we
put machine learning models into
large-scale production
in order to find new medicines i am
going to be
sharing three things in this talk first
off i'm going to let you peek under the
hood to see how our technology platform
works
machine learning and robotics second i'm
going to share a couple of case studies
on how this plays out in practice for
specific diseases
including for coping 19. and then three
i'm hopefully going to have time at the
end to wrap up by sharing our vision for
the future of drug discovery
and what we really mean by our mission
to
decode biology to radically improve
lives
so i'm using recursion if you will as a
case study for how machine learning can
be applied
in industry let me share a little bit
about the company to help
frame the story we are based in salt
lake city utah
we have nearly 200 employees actively
hiring so country
please reach out and we raised over 200
million dollars
to prove out our vision for how to
fundamentally reimagine drug discovery
to be more efficient
we've used the technology platform i'm
about to tell you about to look across
some 500 different disease models that's
really broad in comparison a biotech of
our
size might more normally focus on one
or a small portfolio of diseases
and this is really the main story of
what i'm going to tell you today
how recursion has accumulated one of the
largest
biological imaging data sets in the
world
and of course how we use this data set
our core imaging data set is over four
and a half
petabytes of data that is 4.5
million gigabytes but what we're doing
is
obviously not just collecting data
points uh an even more instructive
uh mental model to think about might be
uh that we are trying to industrialize
drug discovery that is we're creating
standardized
large-scale production processes where
we run the same assay
week after week at massive scale
while iterating through on what we're
testing so
large numbers of potential drugs um
compounds is what we call them and also
large numbers
of very diverse diseases
it's popular i think to compare these
kinds of mental models
like industrialized drug discovery uh
what's happening in the big social media
tech companies
you know arguably there are some of the
original leaders
in digital flexible industrialization so
for example every day
google search capability infrastructure
that same infrastructure
enables nearly six billion personalized
queries
but facebook their core infrastructure
enables
nearly five billion unique um personal
updates
to be shared by users in some 10 000
foot view
what we're doing is similar we're
building one standardized
platform that allow us to probe at
an infinite for practical purposes
number of different
potential drugs and potential diseases
using that same character platform
technology
uh and another way to look at this uh
just since this is a
a longer talking keynote to give you
some
some um sense of how we think about this
problem another way is
to look back in time to be inspired
so recursion is about drug discovery but
if you go back in time
and you look at not the discovery of
drugs but the physical
preparation of drugs um you can see a
revolution that's already happened
well over 200 years 150 years ago
in the pharmaceutical industry where
there was
an inflection points where the physical
preparation of drugs
went from being something that was done
within local pharmacies
when a patient came in on an individual
per patient on demand
basis and then transformed into an
industrial process of automation
laboratory-based
uh industrialization and the results
from that
transformation was just a massive
increase in scale and quality control
and ultimately in the ability for people
like you and i
to have access to high quality drug
treatments
and that was really maybe the dawn of
the modern
pharmaceutical industry and what we
think of
as medicines today
and today we're looking at
companies like recursion and others
creating a similar inflection points in
how
we don't just manufacture drugs but in
rethinking
how drugs are discovered
and why do we need to industrialize drug
discovery
well simply post because approval rates
of new drugs has been stagnant for
nearly 40 years
and r d cost at the same time has gone
up tenfold
so in essence the reason for this is in
part because biology is really complex
and we understand very little of it so
as an industry
we need to find fundamentally new ways
for discovering new medicine um the
traditional approach to drug discovery
might be to start like a hypothesis of
the mechanism of the specific disease
and use this hypothesis to test for new
promising drug candidates
that obviously works um but it's slow
and
much of the let's say lower hanging
fruit has probably already been found
so enter you know the 2000s
and the increasing uh capabilities of
new omix approaches so like genomics
proteomics which
are being designed in ways that can open
new paths forward and i'm going to tell
you today
specifically about a phenomics platform
approach that recursion uses that is
hypothesis three three that means
it does not require us to have a theory
ahead of time
about what pathways or specific proteins
are important
in a given disease but instead what we
do
is final printing that is machine
learning analysis
on human cell images using standard
set disease agnostic fluorescent probes
wise is powerful it's powerful because
it's content rich we can capture
thousands of features from each image
that describe the state of those cells
it's scalable that means that the same
platform and analysis approach can be
used across
many programs it's fast in less than two
weeks
as i will show you later on in this
presentation we can onboard a whole new
area of disease it's cheap
for ten thousand dollars you can run by
more than a hundred
thousand phenoprinting imaging samples
or just two or three proteomics examples
or maybe i don't know 50 transcriptomics
examples
or samples and then finally it's machine
learning
compatible uh on one hand by this i mean
that it takes advantage of lots of
recent advanced
advances in data science right around
image analytics
types of convolutional neural nets
variational auto encoders
multitask networks and so on techniques
that are proven very powerful
on images but maybe more interesting and
unique
is that by having a single scalable
highly controlled assay
we can also physically add in various
controls
to our experiments that will allow us to
do the most powerful machine learning
possible
so a symbiosis between the generation of
data
and the analysis is in machine learning
so let me take a moment to
remind you of the punchline of this
whole talk it works
we have four clinical stage programs
that means
uh four different disease
areas uh we are ready to
test potential drugs in human patients
and with that let's start to learn about
the actual machine learning and the
robotics automation
much of the machine learning we do at
recursion is a form called
representation learning
that means that rather than building
classification models
that focus on a set of predetermined
outcomes
like specific diseases we build high
dimensional
embedding spaces so mathematical
descriptions
um numeric descriptions uh high
dimensional vectors
that can describe cells effectively
across
a large range of possible cell states
so a classification model right might be
am i looking at disease a or bcsp right
is this a cat
or is this a dog that's not what we're
doing
we're providing creating
these high dimensional
descriptors there are upfront
agnostic to the meaning
of those biological states
so this here is a very simplified
version of an embedding space
uh just for the purposes of this
presentation where we've taken
three dimensions something the human
mind can handle instead of the over
thousandths dimensions uh in original
analysis
the red dots you see are various
diseases we tested on our platform and
the blue dots represent potential drugs
that we have tested
against these diseases in this example
compare the
red dot of a disease with a green dot
of healthy cells and what they would
look like
in a high dimensional space and we can
see
some drugs stand out as being promising
of
uh when added to deceased cells um
causing those cells to begin to look
something
like a healthy set of cells should
various types of this uh form of high
dimensional
analysis allow us to understand what's
happening to the cells
in our phenoprinting assay in a way
where each cell state
is unique but it's also giving us a
complex
nuanced information in a way that's
quantifiable and we can then use this
fingerprint assay
in these high dimensional embeddings to
do a number of things
i can give a couple of examples of what
those things are
uh um actually i guess i need to step
back for a second here i'm just showing
some
uh images of microscopy cells from
our assay um just showing what i just
described with words with
some images where we're turning
these microscopy images of healthy cells
of the sea cell
cells of the c cells plus drugs
into these high dimensional
numeric descriptors and with this
uh what we can do is first off of course
find potential compound
hits so that is drugs
that rescue the c cells so that they
look healthy
in our assay in addition and maybe
really interesting and unique is that we
can also quantify
side effects all the things that these
potential drugs do
to the cells that we can pick up in the
microscopy
that have nothing to do with the rescue
of the disease and by and large
a lot of these are unwanted side effects
they might indicate problems uh in
future downstream analysis
uh with that potential drug
uh and then secondly there's all kinds
of more
detailed analysis we can do to
understand these potential drugs better
so use these assays these
representations to begin to predict
toxicity in downstream analysis that
would be done
or understanding the mechanism of action
not just
that the drug works but why it works
and then finally from the example list
here i will talk at the end of this talk
a little bit about
how we can use these images to begin to
build
biological networks um they will let us
make
new types of insights from what
recursion has done
in the past here's just
an example with some real data from a
disease called hereditary hemorrhagic
telegonista and you see some of the
images here
of us adding different amounts
of drug x a compound we tested
on our platform that rescues this
disease
hht and on the right
you see just one example of how we
take this high dimensional data and
compress it in various ways that allow
for easier human analysis
in this tab in this case into an on
target and off target
score like i described on the previous
slide
so that's essentially collapsing this
high dimensional space into
just a vector here
an off-target score that captures the
rest of the insight
and this right here is just another way
to look at the data i just showed you or
the
examples i just showed you conceptually
uh with the video on the last few slides
um this may be a way that some people in
the audience are more familiar with
uh we have a deep learning architecture
that we use to extract deep learning
features so these descriptors
uh of the original high-resolution
microscopy image
across a number of different channels
of fluorescent probes and then we take
these features
and in the examples from the previous
slide for the deceased hht
we deconvolute that into the part
of that set of features they represent
the on perturbation component that is
the component that can take you from
something that looks like a disease cell
to something that looks like healthy
cells
and then an undesired component of that
feature signal so that's
all the other changes that a potential
drug might induce
in the images that uh is not related
to um reverting the effect
of the disease
and here's one more example of real data
for this
in this example looking at
the growth factor tgf beta and the take
him here is just to
reinforce the point i'm making about the
value of representation learning as a
machine learning modeling approach
particularly when you want to do what
we're doing of
building a reusable platform that
can be applied to many problems of the
same type
in this case the different problems for
different diseases that we care about
so tgf beta is a
a primary driver of fibrosis
in a number of debilitating diseases so
for example in pathological wound
healing
it's essentially it's tissue scarring in
places or in ways
that are harmful for the body so what
you see here on the left
uh is again the high dimensional
platform results collapsed into just 2d
for the purposes of this presentations
where you can see one example of a
compound that's direct zero one zero
four nine three seven
that um rescue deceased uh
cells into something uh into uh
looking like healthy cells and then in b
we see us running a traditional
conform low throughput confirmation
assay
for an output collagen which is an
output
related to fibrosis and scar tissue
formation and just confirming
that the results of what we see in our
novel phenomic assay
um can also be capitulated in this case
by this
more targeted low liquid assay and then
similar
um in this second example here
uh on the right we're not taking that
second step uh that
describe of not just finding hits but
understanding why they're hits
uh and in this example um
simply saying in this high dimensional
space
how does the compound we cared about
this hit we found
how does it compare to lots of other
compounds
that we have that we know how they work
and in this case we see that our
compounds
looks a lot in the high dimensional
space like a group of compounds
that affect a protein and a pathway
called alk5
and again you can confirm that this is
indeed
the activity of this compound uh also
with a more targeted assay
specifically looking at alk5 so in a anc
we're taking our high
throughput output agnostic assay
and getting the results that are
otherwise
unattainable if you already knew ahead
of time which of many thousands of
potential
target specific assays uh you were going
to look at
just to highlight one of the benefits of
these of the agnostic
phenomic assay
and how do we practice one of all of
these biology experiments for machine
learning
uh we have a huge robotics laboratory
where we run up to
850 000 wells per week that's
several million microscopy images going
through
on that weekly basis and again
uh four and a half petabytes of data
how much data is that really four and a
half
uh petabytes of data if you took that
quantity and you turn it into standard
high definition movie
and you wanted to watch it from start to
the end you would have to watch that
movie for 24 hours
a day seven dice a week 52 weeks a year
for 200 years
it's a lot of data and that brings us
really to one of
the core points of the talk your machine
learning model
is not worth much if you can't put it
into production
and here i'm showing you a much
simplified snapshot of the digital part
of our pipeline so what happens when the
robotics are done
we're just highlighting a few key areas
for example being able to handle
image uploading at a speed and volume
per second
that is tracking the capabilities of um
compound of companies like twitter
or for our weekly feature extraction
creating these high dimension
high dimensional embeddings or running
the equivalent of
nearly 20 years of single desktop
computing
just uh in that week and then following
that
by analysis and interpretation
of more than 600 million human cells
a week so it's clearly
pretty simplistic to think about what
we're doing is just
applying machine learning to images
there's just massive machinery
that has to sit around these machine
learning models to ensure that we have
high performance standard quality
that the insights have relevance
and so to take just one of the
components here from this
list on this slide if we look at say
image quality
you know we for example use a data
science method to make sure
that our images are in focus so that any
image that goes to our downstream
representation learning models or high
quality images
or let's see consistency execution error
we use machine learning and data science
methods to make sure that all of our
reagents
all the inputs into this
robotics pipeline look the same this
week as they did
last week and as they did year before so
that's another place
where we use machine learning and data
science to ensure that our processes
are high quality and um
like i mentioned briefly before this is
not all digital it's also
physical control systems so for example
controls
that we embed into our experiment
to help our machine learning embeddings
and models so that's actual physical
additions to some experiments that help
us build
the best models possible uh
one example of this from the previous
slide just to dig in a little bit more
uh is around building predictive models
i mentioned this really briefly being
able to
predict what's going to happen
downstream
acids such as toxicity so here's an
example for a specific toxicity assay
called herb
that measures the risk of a compound of
a drug
causing cardiotoxicity toxicity to the
heart
if it was eventually to be given to
patients in here
what i'm showing here with this
enrichment cycle is that
when recursion collects its very large
data sets
to be able to build these types of
predictive models
we also run models during the early
stages
of creating the data sets
in order to make sure that we create
data sets that have lots of the kinds of
examples that we want to see
in order to train our final
predictive in this case cardiotoxicity
model
so in order to do all of this
in high quality at scale uh we're
embedding
various types of machine learning models
throughout the process
of uh creating our new industrialized
systems
in this example in order to create
training sets
and on the right you simply see a chart
showing
uh how both the hit rate the number of
compounds in the positive class is
enriched with this kind of strategy
and how that then uh eventually as the
next step
um causes help us to have higher model
performance
because the models have had
larger and more diverse set of positive
examples
uh to look at during the training of the
machine learning model
and then at the end of uh this big
phenomics platform
of these terabytes of data coming
through
every week we need to be able to show
all of this data of course to our
biologists to our chemists
and to what other drug discovery team
experts
and so another take home is that it's
not enough to have the machine learning
models it's not enough to have the
pipelines
you also have to have tools at the end
to capture all of this data
and all of this complexity while at the
same time
having those tools be easy and quick to
use
so this i think is a
critical area as well that may be often
skipped over in
public discussions about how ai
algorithms how machine learning
can be really used in practice in
industry how do we take
all of these high dimensional embeddings
and
turn those into a series of tools that
allow
our human experts to focus
on the most important data points out of
all of the ones generated
every week and then since the name
of the company's recursion as part of
telling you
about how our technical platform works
i wouldn't want to miss explaining at
least one way that our
industrialized drug discovery process is
recursive
that is uh it is the repeated
application
of the procedure to successive sets of
results
so here's that example uh we take the
output of our economic platform
and we can search um one over a billion
and i think this number is going up very
rapidly but
a billion for for this slide at least so
latest i have updated of commercially
available compounds
uh from various vendors resources
outside of recursion
so that we can very rapidly find the
best next
set to test and then we can iteratively
go through this process run the platform
use our large-scale search capabilities
to find the next set best of compounds
and then rinse and repeat for several
rounds
and uh of course an important part of
this is like how you do the search so
here again
we can combine this with both sort of uh
in industry best practices types of
search
algorithms in addition to our own
in-house tools
for finding compounds that we think are
going to be promising
for the next round of screening
and maybe one other thing that's
interesting about this
slide for people who who care about this
process of
how do you really use machine learning
in practice in real
company settings um is that it also
shows
how our phenomena screening this
technical platform that i've been
talking about today
it doesn't sit in isolation right but it
integrates into what you might call a
full stack
of drug discovery that means with bench
validation
with in vivo animal studies and
eventually somewhere
on the right off of the slide with human
trials
um how is
how is um this platform affecting the
trajectory of recursion
this is a quick summary of the scale
that this platform has grown over since
recursion started
from very small scale semi-manual
process
back just four years ago to a
fundamentally different
level of scale today in 2020 and i don't
even
know if these numbers are completely up
to date
so one take on here is again the
industrialization of the process and how
rapidly
this kind of mindset to the problem
allows you to scale
quickly but second in blue you also see
how we don't need to scale the human
input that we're putting into this
process
in the same way so in 2019 even as we
reached
300 000 of these mini experiments per
week we still only had two human expert
designers
for all of those experiments and today
in 2020
um we don't even have full-time people
dedicated to this process so that kind
of automation of this core technical
platform
means that we can dedicate our human
resources
our brains to both uh pushing on the
next frontiers
of what this platform can do the new
types of predictions
new types of insights as well as on
downstream analysis
just on the most promising compounds
in the follow-up map analysis uh either
on the biology bench
or individual trials
so um you don't have to take my word for
all of this
if you want to pressure test some of
what i've told you
yourself you can we have uh
opened up three gigantic data sets from
our phenomics platform
to the world and all you have to go is
do is to go to rxrx.ai
to download them there is a gigantic set
called rxrx1 that's optimized
for understanding how
you can relate and compare noisy
biological data for many
different batches so for across long
periods of time
because that data sets was collected
over
many many months with rxrx2 where we've
released
both images for immune perturbations for
something very relevant
to drug discovery and also released
our actual deep learning embeddings that
you can play with this data set
even if you are not a machine learning
scientist
and uh able to create um your own
favorite
uh embeddings and model outputs and then
finally uh there's rx rx19
where we released both images and deep
learning embedded
it's uh for our work on code 19.
so i invite you uh to join and to
explore
uh all of these gigantic data sets
yourselves
next i'm going to transition from
talking about the platform
itself to give you these two case
studies starting
with c difficile uh bacterium
what have you heard about for its um
role in various bowel diseases
so here are um some results for cdf
in human cells on a phenomenous platform
and again cdf is involved in colitis
irritable bowel syndrome and so on
and part of what's uh really neat here
and that's
uh demonstrating with these slides again
that the platform is agnostic to how the
drug
compound works so in the red line on the
left is a compound
that targets not the bacterium
but the host so the human it builds up
your defenses against this bacterium and
agree
is a compound that we also found on the
platform that instead
directly targets the bacterium which
will be the more
common way for a drug to work against an
infectious disease and then as you can
see on the right
we can take this uh platform we built
and rapidly turn it around
to test a new disease model so here we
tried a type of e coli
to see if the same compounds would work
in this
somewhat related disease model and we
see that
uh the host targeting compound the one
that protects the human
also protects against this second
platform
so it essentially allows us a way to
both differentiate
between different compounds very rapidly
using the same assay
and also to start from the starting
point of one specific
disease to look at other diseases
related to it
where the same compounds might also work
so rapidly jump
essentially from assay and assay because
of how
this whole platform is set up
uh and just this is really rapidly
quickly just showing you that we can
um confirm uh
these uh host versus bacteria mechanisms
in more targeted less scalable bench
science assays so here's just one of
many examples of that
where you can see that lack of
human cell membrane integrity one of the
hallmarks of the disease caused by
diseases caused by sleep disorder
is rescued by the addition of uh the
compound
uh that we found
in this in the first big
phenotypic screen and
i don't show this the data here but we
also advance this particular compound
scaffold into in viva animal models
and it works there as well for c
difficile so for example
typically you might see animals in the
standard animal acid we use succumb to
death
after two days in the disease model
but with our molecule we increase that
survival rate at day two
by a significant amount
in here it is a third i think final
example
of how the phenomics platform can help
you
uh compared to a traditional biochemical
targeted assays in this case uh help you
to avoid false positives
the x-axis here on the right are the
results in phenomics assay
you can see most of the text and on the
y-axis is a standard single endpoint
biochemical assay
the red circle shows a compound
that worked really well in a single
endpoint assay
but did not work in a cell assay so if
you had done the simple
the more narrow single target assay you
would have
gotten a false positive and likely the
reason
that uh the phenomics platform gave you
a more nuanced picture here's partly in
part
it partly could be that this compound is
not very cell
permeable so it will be picked up but in
other times we also see compounds that
um they work well and that isolate about
chemical assay
but in the full cell context they might
bind to any one
of the other 20 000 proteins in the cell
rather than a specific target
you might have in mind from your single
endpoint
reductionist biochemical assay among
many other problems that might not be
picked up
in the biochemical essay
and then of course each phenomic screen
as i briefly mentioned can anchored into
a detailed
research operating plan and this is a
very high level of what that looks like
for c difficile so that is anchoring the
primary screen
the machine learning analysis
both with sometimes more detailed
secondary assays
such as the cell junction barrier
function assay
all the way down through a compound that
eventually is ready to be tested
in human trials and so what we're doing
today even though i
focused on this core final print screen
and how machine learning robotics
and other new technology tools are being
used there
that's the focus of this talk but we're
also applying that kind of mindset
to that full uh process
and this full pipeline that i'm showing
here
uh and here uh
related to this story of how the
platform really
in practice gets applied
to real world problems do these machine
learning models really
let you do uh answer questions that are
relevant
in the real world um the platform is
really
robust and very reproducible so this is
just showing three
compounds the potential drugs uh that
work
in our core assay and how those results
repeat
and reproduce week after week this is
really important
because one of the core ways that drug
discovery um
platforms like the one i've been showing
here work like how that
initial finding of a compound that
could become a future drug to help
people works
is that chemists need to iterate on your
initial chemistry starting points
just iteratively to get to a chemistry
that's
really optimized uh to be your final
drug
this process is called sar this is
structure this is search for the
structure
activity relationships um and having a
platform that's highly reproducible
and precise uh is critical to allow you
to do that kind of iterative chemistry
where you're replacing parts
over the original compound as shown here
for the core
with abc and as you replace different
parts
you want to be able to in a quantitative
way
see how the results in your assay
change as you replace these different
parts of the original
compound and see if you can find a
compound that is even better
and this kind of iterative process is a
cornerstone of
many drug discovery programs across the
industry and
being able to do it with a high
throughput agnostic
um platform the way we're doing it is
really really powerful
uh and with that first case study i'm
gonna
transition to briefly tell you about uh
the covet
pipeline that we built uh this late
spring
um big take on here is that in less than
four weeks we could go
from this just being an idea in
someone's brain to having
results um coming out from the platform
finding compounds that worked and it
didn't work
and that's including all the the
logistics
around setting it up we've tested uh
one and a half thousand compounds a bit
more uh
and done that both in two different cell
types
and um
again uh share these results both uh on
campbell
and on rxarx.ai as i shared before
it's a lot results but i'm just gonna in
the interest of time
highlight a couple of drugs that you
might have already heard of
uh in the news from the 1600 we tested
so we looked at
drugs that already were in various
stages of testing for
coronavirus cova 19 or related
diseases or that have been approved
for other uh diseases so they're on the
market and considered saved
so one you might have heard of is a
reminder
which did work in
our assay so it means that it was able
to rescue
deceased cells that were being exposed
to covid
and um or inhibit that infection
and cause those cells to look like uh
healthy cells
and as you may know uh from the severe
uh
while at the time was just beginning to
be talked for it's now in various
clinical trials including by gilead
and is also given to patients in
hospitals in the united states
for treatment of cobit under fda
emergency use
authorization so those are things that
happen after we ran this test
here's the second one that you might
have also heard of
hydroxychloroquine another drug
that has been much talked about for kobe
19.
in our hands it showed some efficacy
when we use the commonly
deployed animal model but
at the cost of having very large
unwanted side effects so you can see
that with this back hook in the left
graph for hydroxychloroquine
but importantly once we tested this
compound
in human cells we actually didn't see
any wanted effect any rescue at all
of the coded infection of these cells
and all we saw was large
off-target side effects
secondly in addition to infecting cells
with
uh copic 19 virus we also looked uh
another concern related to kovids so
this is cytokine
storms cytokine storms so this is
uh the humans immune system out of
control
in response to the viral infection or
sometimes
as many of you are aware i'm sure the
out-of-control human immune system could
be a
larger issue than the initial direct
infection itself and here's some graphs
again
showing how we first rapidly build
various cytokine store models and then
tested um a large array
of already approved drugs
in order to see if we can find some that
have a positive effect
of the disease states and there's some
interesting hits in there
and that brings me to my final few
slides
um beyond these examples and the work
that recursion is doing today on
specific disease programs
dozens of specific disease programs
where do we go from here
and what is really our vision for the
future
of industrialized drug discovery
to simplify a bit um the approach i have
shown you up to now
it's one of brute force right like we
don't have a specific hypothesis
just test all the combinations hundreds
of thousands of compounds against
hundreds of diseases just see what
shakes out
but now we're beginning to move to the
next phase
if you have as much data you can take
these massive data sets
and begin to build out predictions in a
map
of human cellular biology essentially
begin to combine results from all the
separate assays we run
in order to reconstruct and discover
cellular pathways and signaling
relationships um so that
we can begin to decide ahead of time
in an ever more clever way which
experiments we should even run
to begin with and so this
slide shows just a tiny subset of genes
that we've tested
on our platform using crispr so we
compare
the high dimensional phenotypic signal
again between
various g knockdowns and begin to take
that to build
one gene a g map of defect on cells
on um
gene knock down and do signal so in the
heat map here
dark red means more similar and vice
versa for blue
so just to like highlight one
one small example from what's actually a
very
large um data sets here
uh knocking out by crispr of kmt2d
in kane uh kdm 6a um
two different genes that are both
involved in the same
uh human disease kabuki syndrome
look very very similar
in our platform showing that for this
very serious multi-system disorder
uh various genetic perturbation that
lead to that same disease
look the same you can imagine beginning
to build up
all sorts of uh powerful insights
about how diseases are related how
potential drugs are related
how potential drugs and diseases are
related
um a priori before the specific
combinations are tested
in our platform and this is showing that
same
uh concepts now looking at compounds
like potential drugs
where you can differentiate between
different mechanistic targets
and also see nuanced sub clustering
within a target class
so here for example for mtor inhibitors
where different compounds
might have different potency so work at
different constantly different
concentrations to work or have different
poly pharmacology
where they're also hitting other targets
in addition to mtor
and building these large-scale maps by
testing
many thousands of different um compounds
of different genes and so on
we can begin to tease out um this kind
of nuance
and then eventually bringing all of
these things together
where we're bringing to we're building
out ever larger
combined comparison maps
of human cells
so that one day we'll be able to predict
things ahead of time such as
which compounds are likely to work in
which disease
or given disease x that i care about
how do i design the most promising
initial compound chemistries
and that's really i think ultimately the
vision of where recursion wants to take
machine learning for drug discovery we
want to use it to decode biology
to build these large-scale maps in order
to radically improve
human lives and with that i'm going to
wrap up
i showed you a bit about how we're
industrializing drug discovery
using machine learning and automation to
recursively around the same assay again
and again
and apply it to many diseases to with
this approach
right we can transition between these
diseases really rapidly
and um bring on new diseases really
quickly like i showed you with a
covalent example
and would see the seal for irritable
bowel syndrome
and then finally uh recursion is now
using this
massive scale to begin to build a map of
human cellular
biology and with that i say thank you
and i invite you for questions
thank you for that talk lena that was
fantastic
um we have some great questions here
from the audience um i'm going to take
the
liberty to paraphrase a little bit um
but let me start by just asking
do you use a specific tissue or cell
types that are physiologically relevant
or does any cell type essentially image
pretty well
um and are there if you have preferences
for 2d versus 3d
all right so we have the capability we
have run
dozens of different cell types we have
the patient cells also in addition
to that so that's a broad span um
but we try to
um to focus in on
certain sets of cell types that are
proven promising in our hands so that we
can really scale and run really rapidly
for the big screens
so there's definitely strategy around
not trying to find
the perfect cell type for every single
application
but really being able to run the initial
screening step
at massive scale which can be hard to do
with certain cell types
i presented before are on the 3d
questions on some work redundant
organoids super
simple beating heart cell organoids and
steroids
and that's something we've done at kind
of a medium scale at recursion and we're
now
looking to do it much larger scale so if
you're interested and you're looking for
a job
reach out so a number of different
techniques
to get to that increased physiological
relevance
and how transferable do you find uh some
of these results are across
cell types do you find that generally if
you've discovered a phenotype in one you
find it in others
uh it all depends on the pathway biology
of the disease so some things drop in a
lot of our different
uh cell types and some things are just
more specific right
to immune cell or neuronal cell etc so
it's a kind of hard question to
generalize on
yeah um
can you talk a little bit more about
sort of the biological interpretation of
the embeddings how
i mean you've shown in your talk there
that there are some ways where you can
sort of try to figure from what's around
it but how easily can you then
turn an embedding into a uh what a
biologist recognizes a phenotype
uh right so i guess the question here is
like having for example features that
are human interpreters
interpretable like the shape and size of
the nucleus the number of mitochondria
et cetera
and early on we did work at recursion
trying
to to match features this way and we
kind of abandoned that as
a strategy basically saying if we truly
want to be targeted agnostics we truly
want to pick up all of the signal from
the cell
it's self-defeating for our approach and
our strategy to try to do that mapping
because if we do that
we're leaving so much on the table just
because it doesn't perfectly match
to something that um we can think about
like in a human interpretable way
and instead we leave that human
interpretability part for later
orthogonal assays where we're trying to
elucidate the mechanism in more detail
and that i think is is the more powerful
way
to really leverage these new deep
learning uh techniques right
uh why the preference for high
dimensional embedding do you have a
sense of the effective dimensionality of
the biology of interest in any of these
cases
yeah this is a really interesting
question i'm interested in this too um
being high dimensional count going to
the last question right allows us to be
totally agnostic about what's important
and what isn't right like for example we
have had mitochondrial diseases where
the signal
um does not map to the mitochondria
specifically or solely
and then those potential drugs that we
found have validated in later
assays so um i think it can narrow what
you're looking at
to get too narrow about what are the
dimensions of the features the things
you care about in the cell so we really
want to get away from that
the kind of biology we've been looking
at to date we
we do have kind of too many dimensions
if you will like we are
where we have too many channels we are
aligning the initial
um feature stations to to spam more
dimensions than we really need
and then we narrow down to what is
actually
important for that particular disease to
determine you know to differentiate
between the healthy and the disease
states
but that's definitely an interesting
question for us right because when
you're running things at these massive
scales
doing that extra bit of work that might
not matter if you're running
one plate or 100 place really starts to
add up
in logistics so we're always for sure
into the future looking at ways that
maybe we can
kind of just make sure that we're
hitting that balance between
capturing enough to capture states that
we might not have anticipated
but not you know going so overboard that
it costs us time and money and
frankly could lead to less signal than
we want more noise
uh how do you incorporate feedback from
the in vivo studies
on a drug so once you get further down
the pipeline how easy is it to
incorporate stuff backward
yeah thanks for that question yeah so uh
we we wrote about some animal studies
also on the most promising hits after
we've done
bench science validation that's the next
stage and as i mentioned in the talk
there are four compounds that are now
also
ready for human clinical trials
and so um we don't today feedback the
specific information from the individual
animal studies
it's a question the problem right of
what are you optimizing for and we have
the number there that you can have is
much smaller than what we can have on
the big platform right
and so we don't want to screw ourselves
too much for that very small test set
so the two things or two of the things
that we've done
um instead to date are one um
testing compounds that are in the clinic
or have been in the clinic
on our platform so um we tested hundreds
and i haven't talked about the details
of this publicly before so i can't
really
get in the weeds about it but we've
tested lots of hundreds of compounds
that are available on the market on our
platform to confirm
that the platform can do um what we
think you can and use that
to um to
help improve and iterate on the deep
learning another
thing that we do today is one very large
massive massive experiments
simply for this map of biology right
then again lets us improve
um the general deep learning algorithms
to
distinguish between biological states
better and then the third thing i guess
i should say
and is that we have bought a company
called biome a while back that's public
information too and that is
a in vivo
research company that uses machine
learning techniques
at the individual stage and we will have
some ability for us
to kind of tackle that part uh in a way
that
um it kind of works with the way
recursion operates
without letting us hang on to very small
numbers of renewable results
uh a question that just came in that i
think is
really interesting um you highlighted
the importance of consistency
um reagents images things like that how
do you balance
keeping consistency with embracing new
technology
oh interesting yeah
your fierce debate
yeah this is uh really tricky right and
i mean maybe this is like a human
uh kind of like how you work together
questions so we divide up our
our work into things that are divided
into like the maintenance that we
already have
building off of that specific work and
then
a whole area of bold bets within
recursion
where there are groups of people just
focused on rethinking how things
how fundamentally how we do things like
there was the questions about
the mathematical space we used around
cosine similarity yeah
i saw and like that's not the only way
to do it but the cost
of switching obviously in a pipeline
like this
is really high so we have separate teams
uh whose job it is to say
what could this look like in a year in
five years and let's build that out
and then take the most promising things
and integrate that into the main
platform
it's tricky for sure yeah i i can only
imagine
um time just for one or two more
questions uh one question that i had
personally
is the release of all of those public
data sets
uh what benefit do you hope those will
have for the community and is there any
benefit that you hope that specifically
those will give to recursion the release
of those public data sets because
putting things together like that is
quite a bit of work
yeah for sure i mean we i think
the machine learning community is really
good about what sharing and
and um the field that's really been
spurred
by that kind of attitude of putting not
just results but also tools out like
google's tensorflow etc there's lots of
examples of that
it's hard as a small company to
contribute to that and to balance
like you growing and doing that work and
putting out these data sets is i think a
great way for us to give back to the
community
and be part of that kind of a mindset
and way of operating
so i mean fundamentally it's just like
it feels good and we want more people to
be working
on these problems um but then i mean for
recursion we're hoping that people see
those data sets and
decide they want to come and work with
us and play with the other 99.9
of the data and we have had that and
then um
of course it's a way for us to show um
that
what we're doing is real right
yeah it's there really some some
phenomenal um
resources um and the last question i'll
go ahead and ask is um do you have a
sense of the range of mechanisms that
can't be detected by the platform
what are the limitations that you guys
are working to overcome to the degree
you can talk about it
yeah in a couple months
so we are we're doing great the big big
research work on this in-house running
large experiments to try to get a better
sense of this
where is morphological profiling going
to be the most
promising you can use those insights to
guide what kind of licenses we work on
and then in addition
what are the complementary methods that
uh we want to
scale further at recursion um to capture
the broadest biology possible
yeah but i think it's both kind of an
intrinsic question about
morphological signals but there's also
something here right about
continuing to improve deep learning
models continuing to improve
um the process of actually running the
experiments
i don't think we or or anybody has
really reached the limits
of what can be seen in morphological
imaging all right so
i think there's a lot more uh just
improved methods
uh to get at so i guess there's a
question of what can we see today
and there's a question of what do we
need to do to capture even more
i i think that's a fantastic uh note to
end on
thank you so much for your time thank
you everyone for your attendance we
really appreciate all the great
questions
uh please enjoy the rest of the sbi 2
meeting